hallo liebe leute und frohe weihnachten
heute ist der 24
dezember 2015 und ihr erinnert euch
vielleicht die 24 dezember feiert man in
deutschland traditionell weihnachten
letztes jahr vielleicht erinnert ihr
euch noch haben wir ja hier seht ihr die
episode noch mal auf der straße gefragt
wie die menschen in münster weihnachten
feiern und wir haben dort viele
spannende sachen herausgefunden
dieses jahr möchten wir euch mal
mitnehmen und zeigen wie wir weihnachten
feiern
los geht's
ja meine familie feiert traditionell im
haus von meinen eltern das heißt
weihnachten kommen wir alle zurück nach
münster wohnen für ein paar tage
zusammen in diesem haus das besondere
bei unserer weihnachtsfeier ist dass wir
nicht nur die familie einladen denn
unsere familie ist relativ klein wir
sind nun zwei schwestern keine tanten
onkels oma opa die kommen
deshalb haben wir vor ein paar jahren
angefangen freunde einzuladen und zwar
freunde aus dem ausland die in
deutschland leben aber weihnachten nicht
bei ihren familien verbringen können
oder vielleicht gar kein weihnachten
feiern weil sie zum beispiel keine
christen sind und so verbringen wir
dieses weihnachtsfest dieses jahr mit
neuen leuten in diesem haus ja jetzt
sind wir schon in der küche her hier
wird eifrig vorbereitet schon heute
abend ihr seht das festmahl wird
vorbereitet und hier ist lang
sie lernt deutsch beim kochen hey wie
gehts dir weh giske ach lang hat ein
neues wort gelernt
der ca hier lernt jemand weihnachten
deutsch ist das nicht möglich
das worauf man als kind aber auch als
erwachsener wartet am weihnachten ist
die bescherung die bescherung kreis dass
wir uns gegenseitig geschenke geben
früher haben wir noch daran geglaubt
dass das christkind in manchen ländern
auch der weihnachtsmann die geschenke
bringt heute wissen wir natürlich dass
die geschenke nicht vom weihnachtsmann
kommen sondern wir geben uns gegenseitig
geschenke und hier seht ihr wie wir das
machen wir haben für jede person die bei
uns feiert hier das zum beispiel ist
mein haufen kann wir einen namen und
dahinter tun wir die geschenke für diese
person und später sitzen wir dann hier
mit allen leuten zusammen und jeder darf
immer reihum ein geschenk aufmachen
es hat geklingelt
hallo wer kommt denn da ist dass der
weihnachtsmann
ich bin jetzt berühmt
wo kommst du bekommst du dann gerade
hierher von zu hause
ich habe einige stecken nämlich
angepackt wo sind deine geschenke in der
tasche gefasst jetzt geschenk ein ja ja
ja wir sind das ganze jahr zukaufen
grafik gestern alles ein oder ein paket
das ist jetzt gerade freut sich schon
auf die bescherung auch der was
bescherung es passiert wenn ihr nicht
ist jankos hier steht in manche wörter
nicht was heißt das bisher ist doch der
das wichtigste am abend wenn wir uns die
geschenke geben was soll ja klar
natürlich weil ich ja ich bin jetzt hier
in meinem alten kinderzimmer
das heißt als kind und als jugendlicher
habe ich in diesem zimmer gewohnt und
heute bin ich noch als gast hier
manchmal und wir packen jetzt geschenke
ein
wie packt man geschenke ein man braucht
natürlich geschenkpapier eine schere
tesafilm und das wichtigste sind
natürlich die geschenke ja was
verschenke ich dieses jahr ich
verschenke eigentlich nur gar nicht so
große sachen dieses jahr sondern nette
und liebe sachen da haben wir zum
beispiel bilder von der familie hier
sieht man ein familienzelt viel das ist
auf einer wand gedruckt das kriechtier
sie meine schwester natürlich verschenke
ich auch bücher und dieses jahr haben
wir zwei mädels bei uns die ganze neu
sind in deutsch lernen die kommen aus
pakistan und aus dem jemen
achim habt ihr eben schon gesehen und da
ich ihnen helfen möchte beim
deutschlernen beim anfang bekommen sie
dieses bilder wörterbuch und ihr könnt
mal reingucken
in diesem bilder wörterbuch seht ihr
immer ein bild und ein wort ganz einfach
also es gibt immer so themen der
kindergarten und dann werden die
gegenstände gemalt und auf deutsch ist
das wort runter und man kann dann in
seiner muttersprache antwort
unterschreiben ja und jetzt haben wir
noch ein special für euch denn ich habe
das buch nicht nur zwei mal gekauft
sondern dreimal
eins ist quasi ein weihnachtsgeschenk
für euch ihr könnt dieses buch gewinnen
was müsst ihr machen ihr schickt uns ein
video und in diesem video zeigt er uns
wie sehr ihr euch freuen würde wenn ihr
dieses buch bekommt und die person die
sich am meisten freut die kriegt das
buch das video könnt ihr unten in den
kommentaren verlinken wir sind schon
gespannt auf eure antworten
und irgendwer von euch wird dann
demnächst dieses buch zu weihnachten aus
deutschland geschenkt bekommen ja jetzt
unsere weihnachtsfeier angefangen wir
haben erst angefangen und haben sekt
getrunken
jetzt gibt es die bescherung das heißt
alle packen nacheinander aus und das
dauert ungefähr zwei stunden so viele
leute sind sie was hast du denn bekommen
wunderschön ist familien geld bekommen
hast du dich gefreut
total wirklich also echte das sehr sehr
schön dass er hier so tolles material um
kreative habt ihr bein retten was für
deine wohnung und das ist für die nach
hause
was ist denn das schönste für dich ein
weihnachtsfeiern mit dem hinterkopf
haben dass sie jemand hier gebracht war
aber ansonsten fast schon sein
eine gute zeit haben das war alles
voraussagen kommen gleich noch essen
trinken
ok ich fange jetzt mein geschenk aus
oder dass länder frühstückskorn danke an
dass er wird sich schon früher warst du
meinen easyjet zuschauer und jetzt
feiert mit uns weihnachten ja so schnell
kann's gehen seht ihr liebe zuschauer 27
nächstes jahr feiert er mit uns macht
das haus zu groß genug also zuerst
einmal in deutschland weihnachten
gefeiert hatte war das ein kulturschock
oder war das ähnlich zu weihnachten in
brasilien ein bisschen jahren also die
menge der geschenke war mir ein bisschen
überraschen
ja was schon ein bisschen zu viel so
viele geschenke gar nicht irgendwie
gleich so uns jahren wir fahren weil
einfach mitte familie wir essen was wir
trinken was zusammen
manche singen aber das waren geschenke
kleinigkeiten sind bei uns auch gleich
ein
ja ja aber die menge und sind richtig
viele viele geschenke viele menschen
viel zeit ja so ist deutschland
andere soll
was machst du da warst du wer also viele
schränke
hast du dir für das essen an bringen
willst du trinken jetzt ein
traditionelles portugiesisches via licht
in anderes gesicht oder professional
sie hat einen lockenwickler zu
weihnachten bekommen magic liebe
zuschauer jetzt haben wir eben gegessen
aber wir waren so beschäftigt mit den
geilen essen das wir vergessen haben
euch zu zeigen wie das aussieht
deswegen stellen wir das jetzt noch
einmal nach was haben wir dann gegessen
kartoffeln raclette kartoffeln schön in
deutschland schön kartoffeln gegessen
käse und wie warm raclette gemacht dass
sie es ein breites gerät und wie
funktioniert das
also es funktioniert ihnen denn man
verschiedene sei hier darauf zum
beispiel kartoffeln käse schinken
paprika zwiebeln 30 gucken mal alles
möglich champignons champions auch noch
alles möglich da kann man hier in diesem
gebiet hier rein schon dass wir da jetzt
und käse wie zum beispiel der drei drauf
ist wie verschmolzen schmilzt der
richtig ist käse immer überall käse
drauf genau und dann kann man das essen
ist sehr einfach
jeder brennt sich sein eigenes gericht
ja was macht man nach dem essen wir
feiern weiter und wir machen etwas was
nicht ganz typisch ist für ein deutsches
weihnachtsfest aber in unserer familie
feiern wir so nach dem essen laden wir
alle unser
nachbarn und freunde ein wir bringen ein
paar
bierchen libri ein paar gitarren dazu
und musikinstrumente und dann trinken
wir zusammen und machen musik
wir danken euch fürs zuschauen das war
schon mit der heutigen episode wir haben
euch kurz gezeigt wie wir weihnachten
feiern
es ist vielleicht nicht ganz typisch
aber auch trotzdem ein bisschen typisch
normalerweise die hatten so viele
ausländer dem tisch
aber wir freuen uns ja international
weihnachten ist ja unser markenzeichen
geworden in der familie schmidt danke
fürs zuschauen vergesst nicht wenn er
das buch gewinnen wollt mit den tausend
wörtern das bild tausend worte bilder
bilder wörterbuch dann schickt uns ein
video und zeigt uns wie sehr ihr euch
freuen würden über dieses buch und der
sich am derjenige der sich am meisten
freut kriegt dann das buch eingeht fürs
zuschauen danke dass ihr dabei weit
weihnachten und grüße nach kolumbien
brasilien china russland frankreich nach
afrika nach ägypten wo immer ihr seid
doch ich verließ maria verließ nach
wieder völlig nach